[Música]
que es y no mata
qué signo vale para ustedes estamos en
una era de transformación digital
escucharon ese término parece que muchas
tecnologías están cambiando nuestro
presente y sobre todo están construyendo
nuestro futuro
qué es innovar es por ejemplo usarán
robots
estamos en una era de robotización y
automatización dice el banco mundial que
los argentinos escuchen este dato
lideramos el ranking global de países
que tienen trabajos que pueden ser
automatizados qué hacemos con esta
información por otra parte si te vas
alemania que es el país más robotizado
del mundo te encontrás con que el
desempleo es menor al 4% entonces parece
que robotizar o automatizar no
necesariamente significa que vengan a
quedarse con nuestro trabajo sin embargo
a nosotros nos da cierto miedo este
avance no bueno no se preocupen porque
miren no le salen también las cosas
todavía
yo creo que nos reímos un poco de
nervios porque ensaya dos días más y lo
va a hacer mejor que nosotros seguro lo
cierto es que no tiene mucho sentido
pensar a la tecnología en contra de las
personas la tecnología puede ser una
herramienta para hacernos cada vez más
humanos puede ser así otra de las
grandes instrucciones que vienen en
tecnología tiene que ver con la
inteligencia artificial otro de los
términos de moda que seguramente lo han
escuchado que es la inteligencia
artificial no es nada más y nada menos
que sistemas que empiezan a hacer cosas
que hasta ahora éramos propias de la
inteligencia humana empiezan distintos
sistemas que hacemos las personas a
resolver esposas que ahora las hacíamos
nosotros pero parece que empiezan a
hacer las cada vez más máquinas
podríamos decir bueno se están
automatizando los trabajos hay
inteligencia artificial es pero yo soy
periodista tengo un trabajo súper
creativo un robots una manía
y una inteligencia artificial no puede
hacer lo que hago esto o quizás si
puedes
[Música]
d
bueno este muchacho chino se vino a
quedar con mi laburo les cuento que
trabaja en el horario central en china
es una inteligencia artificial que
cuenta las noticias y no solamente eso
sino que las agencias de noticias más
importantes del mundo están a través de
bots
es decir robots de software produciendo
miles y miles de noticias a diario
entonces una vez más que hacemos nos
preocupamos con esta información o
pensamos cuáles serán las habilidades
que tenemos que desarrollar para
trabajar con estas tecnologías es
importante pensar a la inteligencia
artificial porque estamos en un momento
en la que se está creando de qué se
alimenta la inteligencia artificial de
nuestras opiniones de nuestros centros
de nuestra información miren lo que pasó
con este el experimento en twitter
pusieron a un bot a aprender de las
personas y este modo de nuestra
y terminó escribiendo hitler no hizo
nada malo
una vez más somos las personas las que
tenemos que estar en el centro pensando
cómo estamos creando las tecnologías del
futuro y miren lo que le pasó a esta
aerolínea una mujer subió un avión pidió
su menú es clara es celíaca se quejó
porque no estaba de menú de segi latas
por celíacos y que le contesta el voto o
la celíaca
yo tengo la impresión que esta mujer no
va a volver a tomar esa aerolínea y va a
tomar otra entonces una vez más que es
innovar es innovar usar biotecnología es
otra de las grandes instrucciones que se
viene a nuestra vida la biotecnología
combina a la naturaleza ya la tecnología
y empieza a crear cosas que hasta ahora
eran impensadas como muebles que parecen
de madera pero no son de madera o clara
de huevo que no necesito a un huevo o un
whisky que tiene un gusto de whisky
alejado pero se hizo en 7 días en un
laboratorio o una campera de cuero que
no necesitó un animal para hacerse todo
esto también está pasando ahora y la
biotecnología cambiará nuestras
profesiones hondamente en los próximos
años
podría seguir contándoles esto y muchas
más impresiones 3 de todo lo que tiene
que ver con el adn porque a eso me
dedico a contar la innovación mi trabajo
como periodista de tecnología se trata
de meterme en las industrias más
variadas para poder contarlas así un día
tengo la posibilidad de ir a la nasa y
ponerme un traje de astronauta y tratar
de entender cómo es vida otro día pude
estar en tierra del fuego viendo cómo
las mujeres ensamblaban televisores y
entender su trabajo también en las
fábricas y otro día pude visitar la casa
central de google para entender cómo
hacer esos productos que usamos nosotros
a diario
también tuve la posibilidad de leer mis
ondas cerebrales pero no les voy a decir
lo que salió de ahí otro día pude cantar
en este robot de google que él cuando el
auto de 'street view' vieron es el que
toma las imágenes por la calle cuando no
entra el auto se pone en ese robot que
tiene cientos de cámaras 360 con las que
toman las imágenes que después nosotros
disfrutamos y otra vez puede estar
adentro de un quirófano para ver cómo
operaba el robot más avanzado del mundo
mi trabajo como periodista me da este
privilegio de preguntarle a los que
crean la tecnología como la crean tuve
la posibilidad de preguntarle al creador
de netflix de wikipedia de linkedin de
mercadolibre cómo es innovar qué es
innovar y tratar de pensar qué tiene que
ver esa innovación con nosotros pero por
sobre todas las cosas lo que más me
permite mi trabajo es conocer historias
a mí me encanta contar historias y creo
que la tecnología fue la excusa que
encontré para hacerlo por ejemplo como
la historia de emilia ustedes ven ahí un
chaleco amarillo pequeño metido adentro
de una turbina emilia tiene 26 años y en
la primera tejen y está certificada
argentina todos sus compañeros son
varones y ella la unam y 6 a la
primavera y es cerca de los aviones y la
primera técnica más para certificada de
una aerolínea internacional trabajando
en esa isla
que se animó a innovar a ir por sus
sueños ella es vanessa varadura vanessa
es sorda y creó una aplicación para
poder comunicarse mejor y que las
personas puedan entenderla mejor o una
aplicación que tiene unos muñequitos que
van contando y conversando con las
personas para que entiendan su sordera y
puedan habilitar mejor la comunicación
otro día me tocó ir a la casa de la
familia casi son los cuatro sordos
cuando llegué florencia de 27 años me
dijo bienvenida somos una familia de
sordos
milos y mateo perdieron la audición al
año florencia aprendió a hablar a los 27
años y empezó a través de un implante
coclear toda la familia tiene implantes
saben que fue lo que más me impresionó
no fue el implante de tecnología
florencia me dijo que a los 27 años por
primera vez se enteró de una caricia
tiene sonidos y también se enteró por
primera vez que cuando hace a su amante
y el agua cae en la hierba
eso también tiene un sonido
todas esas cosas que nosotros damos por
sentadas florencia las descubrió a los
27 años a través de la tecnología
y otro día quizás uno de los más
importantes que me tocó vivir me pude
sentar en la esquina de un quirófano en
un hospital público en posadas en
misiones y ver como tres cirujanos
argentinos que estudiaron en la
universidad pública operaban a una mujer
con tumor maligno a través de la mini el
robot más avanzado del mundo
es saltar en nuestro país en el norte
argentino en un hospital público y vi
como durante 5 horas lanzaron el robot y
los tres cirujanos y lograron que esta
mujer pobre que había viajado mucho para
poder ser operada en 24 horas pueda
volver a su hogar que es innovar
y eso con francisco y jessica los conocí
el año pasado tienen el síndrome de
asperger y se animó a los major formas
empezaron a trabajar en una empresa de
tecnología porque las personas con más
parejas tiene un poder cognitivo y de
foco superior al de las personas que lo
no tenemos las personas con autismo
tienen un foco y una atención que las
personas que no lo tenemos no y ellos
ahora son los rockstars del departamento
de analistas en una empresa de
tecnología
es esto también innovar
me puse a pensar y a buscar entonces
cuáles son los rangos de las personas
más innovadoras y como una buena noticia
dice el foro económico mundial que en el
futuro tendrán trabajo las personas que
apuesten a sus habilidades blandas han
escuchado eso que son las habilidades
blancas son estas habilidades
interpersonales digitales muy ancladas
en nuestro ser humano y que creo que
justamente son las que en la robótica y
en la exte licencia artificial muchos no
se pueden desarrollar al menos por ahora
y encontré que una de las
características las personas más
innovadoras es que son perseverantes
la perseverancia es un motor de
innovación y la subestimamos dice en
este dato en medio insistí hable pero me
gusta mucho así que espero que sea real
que thomas edison provocó en 1600
filamentos hasta dar con el filamento de
la lamparita eléctrica
y que probó hasta con las barbas de un
amigo para ver si podía conducirla por
ahí cuantas veces intentamos 1600 veces
las cosas creo que no muchas son por
otra parte me pongo a pensar en qué
difícil es perseverar no hay mucho error
nos equivocamos a la hora de intentar el
error también en lugar de innovación las
personas más innovadoras las que están
creando el futuro no tengan dudas que
hernando los días hay grandes errores
para que después haya grandes éxitos lo
que está logrando ahora por ejemplo el
más demandar o ellos al espacio y
estacionar nos lo logró luego de
estrellar decenas de cohetes sin intento
no hay innovación sin error no hay
innovación una vez más que es innovar
estaba también en otro de los rasgos de
las personas innovadoras y tiene que ver
con la resiliencia que es la resiliencia
la resiliencia es esta posibilidad de
seguir adelante más allá del contexto
cuando hay aridez cuando hay dolor
cuando no hay posibilidad cuando hay
miedo qué innovadora es hacer cosas más
allá del miedo hoy las personas más
innovadoras los líderes más innovadores
muestran la vuelta de habilidad dicen yo
solo no puedo piden ayuda no sé a
ustedes pero a mí me criaron con que el
que no hay que medir altura y que el
error tampoco está permitido
de hecho me pusieron una etiqueta que
decía martí todo lo puede
mi mamá me decía son la columna
vertebral de la familia imagínense lo
que empieza esa mochila la ponen caminar
como hace para pedir ayuda si te dijeron
que vos todo lo podés como hago para
decir tengo miedo
hace 20 años que terminé la escuela y
ese día empecé a trabajar y no hay un
solo día que no tenga miedo en lo que
hago tuve miedo para pararme acá tuve
miedo para conducir el programa de radio
a las siete de la mañana tuve miedo para
encarar las notas que encare ayer pero
más allá de ese miedo me animo a salir y
avanzar y eso tiene que ver con la
resiliencia cómo avanzar y creer que se
puede crecer una flor en el desierto
con respecto a esto pensaba también en
que nada de lo que nos pasa nos
determina nada de lo que te pasa te
determina a mis 15 años la enfermedad
que tenía mi papá hizo que sea una época
bastante compleja en mi vida yo estaba
pensando que quería estudiar cuando sea
grande tenía una cierta búsqueda de
vocación por el contar pero era una
época difícil mi papá era difónico y
cuando hay alcohólico en la familia
todas las familias enfermas y era muy
difícil seguir mis sueños estaba triste
tenía una angustia que todavía el
acierto la siento físicamente me
constituye pero no me frena al contrario
me impulsa me impulsa y me hace
agradecer
y me orgullo eso la familia que tú ves
que tengo
pensaba entonces en que innovador es
seguir más allá de la resiliencia
en el medio de todo eso suena dormía en
casa porque es un caos dormía en la
escuela no lo hagan en la universidad
pero me iba haciendo atrás
mis amigos me tapaban con camperas y yo
escuchaba la radio y soñaba con ser uno
de ellos escuchaba la radio decía yo
quiero cuando tiene un programa de radio
y el portal ovi entonces entre este daño
que hice me cambié del colegio
inesperadamente me cambié de colegio
para seguir periodismo yo sabía que
quería contar me y también el colegio y
el día que terminé el secundario
en esta universidad es estudiar
periodismo
y esto me hace pensar en la vocación y
qué tiene que ver la vocación con la
innovación las personas más innovadoras
tienen muy en claro su propósito para el
que hago lo que hago para que así lo que
hace
es una pregunta que me hago todas las
semanas en mi trabajo y me genera
respuestas muy incómodas porque muchas
veces la respuesta no me gusta me
encuentro haciendo cosas que no tienen
que ver con mi propósito cosas que no me
sirven a hacer esa persona que quiero
hacer cosas que me alejan de mi pasión
pero a veces buscando bien y cuando
encuentro historias como la de manera
como la de francisco como la de jessica
como la de los precisos me acuerdo cuál
era mi pasión y me acuerdo de donde vino
esa pasión yo me encontré que innovar
para mí era perseguir mis sueños y
entonces me fijé de dónde venían esos
sueños y me encuentre con esto
[Música]
bueno
encontré que mi primera entrevista para
los 5 años familia maristas se les están
preguntando si se casó o no fue acaso
las días está muy feliz con la decisión
también está bueno saber eso
para mí innovar tiene que ver con romper
con lo establecido y tratar de mejorar
innovar es mandar boyas a la luna esos
servicios tecnología es hacer robótica
es hacer la inteligencia artificial pero
también es mirar las cosas de todos los
días como una vida de nuevo
para mí innovar es animarse a seguir los
sueños
vos te animas a innovar es gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]